Previously you've seen
the view did load gets called,
when the view controller
class is loaded into memory.
This diagram illustrates the view and
view controller life cycle.
When the view in view controller
are changing states, these functions,
if you have implemented them,
will get called.
In iOS, the will functions always
get called before the did functions.
If YouWill appear,
gets called before the view
controller in its view are onscreen.
If YouDid appear,
gets called right after the view and
view controller are on screen.
This is really useful if you want
something to happen right before or
right after a view
controller's view appears.
If you override these functions in your
view controller, they will get called.
Otherwise, their default
in empty implementations
in the UI view controller class,
will get called instead.
The last point bears repeating, as it
is a common error I've seen many times.
If you mistyped the function
name it's not the same function.
For example,
view will appear as you see here.
Has an extra P,
into IOS it is a completely different
function than the one it's looking for.
So I would never call this function,
even though, our code would compile.
Remember, programming is an exercise
in trying to be as precise as possible.
Don't worry too much though,
Xcode autocomplete will help you
in filling out the names
of these functions.